Leana difficult start the tournament but
we could still see you on camera smiling
enjoying every single moment with your
uh friends and teammates because you
guys are creating some sort of a team
they analyzing these positions and we've
actually seen the influence of that you
in the last game against Sam shanglin
decided to go with G6 defend upon on H7
like that but it wasn't a comfortable
position at all take us through this
game take us to tell us how you adjusted
after that first game um you know
generally I was playing play well in
that first game it's just that I lost my
cool in the winning position so I just
told myself you know I got to play the
same and maybe not go down on time so
much but this position oh my God from
move one we realized when we're
analyzing it's a difficult position all
the way yeah yeah we we really couldn't
figure out what to play here because I
thought C5 is is a very dangerous
symmetry with this n G3 and u c yeah C5
I thought Knight Knight G3 CD and C3
were worried about this stuff yeah we
thought to take D and6 takes ah but E6
yeah yeah I think maybe we we
overestimated so the problem with D5
being yeah H4 or E4 this things are
super scary you don't like it this one
yeah for good reason yeah C6 didn't feel
right but I what what happened we we
mostly assume that people are going to
play first move C4 or C3 which we
thought C3 was very strong on move one
you know C3 we thought is even stronger
because it kind of forces black because
now if G6 C4 seemed unpleasant yes and
now the bishop Pawn G7 is going to be
blocked by yeah yeah yeah and if you
play Knight G6 and H4 or you know this
uh yeah this this felt extremely
dangerous for black yep and one of those
positions one of of those positions yeah
yeah and you don't have an engine to
analyze with you have to work with your
team which is the closest engine you can
get the engine in human form yes um a
beast a beast
uncaged and here I realized I'm in a lot
of trouble I hated my possession because
I can't do anything because if I play B6
then Knight D4 is so annoying you know
uh because Bishop D7 B4 that's it my
play stopped and he just developed so so
I thought I just have to be
the yeah now play stops a bishop D7 I
think because I cannot allow F5 yes ah
F5 here is also killing him yeah yeah no
I had to be a Sitting Duck so I thought
well you know I'll just exchange the
Rooks and the Bishops and I'm in you
know it's a difficult position for me
Knight G4 Knight H6 Knight G4 Knight H6
what can I do what can I do but these
were the best moves it felt like finally
you're getting some play in you exchange
one critical piece and then finally now
I started kind of feeling that I'm
surviving after C5 I felt that C5 this
is already this is already more or less
okay I'm still slightly
worse but I Will Survive somehow but
then C4 of course it was a pleasant
surprise mhm because here I saw I can
play B5 B6 but I thought B6 is more
conceptually right I I want to restrict
his Knight keep the and here I think yes
uh Sam started playing very dubious
moves Rook D1 is very dubious no I have
to say he did not find the right plan to
and he had to stay put not do anything
uh rash I think he panicked somehow when
he realized that a good position that he
had is becoming you know not clear yeah
yeah and he gave you the pawn you took
it and after that you converted quite
beautifully I have sale of on a good
start for you um how did you prepare for
this tournament what's different about
Chess 9x compared to classical chess um
what are the big differences I think you
you really need to see tactics so I did
train some tactics before a tournament
because the game can get very sharp as
you probably saw in my game against Ry
yes yes yeah it got really really sharp
at some moment and uh yeah I was happy
that I could see all of this so and one
thing you do very well is you almost
never get in time trouble and if you do
your opponent is in time trouble also
how do you prepare for that how do you
force yourself to have that mental I
know that this is my weakness you know
playing in uh time trouble and well I
lost the first game basically because of
that so I try to avoid getting in time
trouble I mean if I can sometimes you
can't avoid it but it's um just the
experience that
I have some negative experience which is
also a positive experience because you
know you learn from everything yes
leavon thank you very much we'll see you
tomorrow thank you uh leavon indeed as
uh leavon is one of the